Microsoft announced they are
discontinuing their clip art program yes
this is a real story they're getting rid
of all of it they're getting rid of this
stuff completely nobody newses it
anymore it's corny and it's dated
well Andy you couldn't be more wrong in
my opinion
I know art when I see it okay don't
laugh at that yeah
you hired me didn't you yeah exactly I
know fine art I happen to be a huge
collector the second I heard this news I
called Microsoft I got him on the phone
and I bought up their entire collection
of clip art I bought it all and now I
own all of Microsoft's old clip art all
of it you want to see these masterpieces
[Music]
these are all actual this is all actual
real clip art images from windows here
they are this first one I call
I just saw my Master's erection I call
this one our terrorist group needs more
calcium these are real by the way that's
a real piece of clipart
very useful this one's called pizza
pretends to be happy while secretly
wondering if he's watermelon
here's genetics screw-up at the bird
research facility I call this one after
just one more operation on my hand I'll
be 100% Pakistani
[Applause]
what does that clipart so sorry folks
it's discontinued look at this next one
this is called the only known baby
picture of sloth from the Goonies look
at this one this guy's saying we'll just
have to find a state where we can get
married 40 I call this one let's ignore
this small child until he goes away I
call this one this prescription should
help with your hallucinations this this
one's called use this toilet if you have
to make number four and finally I call
this one we're financially secure since
we sold Suzy's leg
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you